Most olvasom a hatalom 48 törvényét
Rubber Greenytől, és egyszerre egy
iszonyatosan gusztustalan és
visszataszító könyv, és egyszerre egy
elgondolkoztató könyv, ami amit nagyon
élvezek. Azért tetszik ez a könyv, mert
bár sok mindennel nem értek egyet benne,
sok mindent én legalábbis személyesen
nem használnék, de mégis azért észre
kell vegyem, hogy az a világ, amiben
élek, és sokszor így működik. Csak egy
példa a 16. törvény az, hogy használd a
távollétedet arra, hogy a megbecsülést
és a tiszteletet növeld másokban. Vagyis
arra utal, hogy minden, ami hiányzik,
annak az értéke megnő. És azt látom,
hogy rendszeresen használják ezt az
emberek. Például a nárcisztikus
személyek a csenddel szokták büntetni a
környezetüket, vagy egyszerűen nem
jelennek meg. Eltűnnek. eltűnnek az
életünkből, eltűnnek és hagynak maguk
mögött egy űrt, és az ember utána tépi
magát, hogy vajon mit mondhattam, vajon
lehet mégis csak neki van igaza eszünkbe
jut, hányszor tévedtünk, hányszor
hibáztunk az a a abb a kapcsolatba, és a
végén pedig elbizonytanolódva
valahogy szenté javatjuk. Valójában ha
ott lenne, akkor viszont válaszolnia
kellene, és ezt viszont nem akarja,
lehet nem is tudná.
Ennek ellenére elgondolkozható ez a
könyv, hogyha észrevesszük máshonan ezt
a dinamikát, akkor tudjuk, hogy ő
alkalmazza ezt a törvényt. Nyilván nem
azért, mert olvasta a könyvet, hanem
azért, mert spontánul ebbe az irányba
tendál az ember.
لا